[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag bonjour à
tous bienvenue sur sensation en
association avec TV 78 je suis
aujourd'hui avec Grégory tranchant et
Guy bétonneau je suis plus connu pardon
sous le nom de torrent le laby bonjour
bonjour alors vous êtes donc un duo de
copain mais aussi un duo d'artiste vous
vous produisez ensemble sur scène
comment en êtes-vous arrivé à créer
votre propre duo
ben en fait on s'est connu en
travaillant en fait on était dans
l'animation et tout de suite on c'est
tout de suite bien entendu et on a même
fait en fait pendant le covid on avait
fait une musique
enregistré une musique et partir de là
je crois qu'on a commencé à faire des
des choses sympas et on a continué et
puis alors c'était justement la musique
c'était déjà quelque chose que vous qui
vous passionnez avant déjà de vous
rencontrer
je sais que j'ai commencé à en faire je
devais avoir 22 ans
après j'en ai eu un second et je l'avais
d'ailleurs en parallèle au moment où
j'ai rencontré Guy et donc c'est pour ça
qu'en fait on s'est rencontré on n'a pas
tout de suite fait de la musique
ensemble il me disait qu'ils faisaient
de la guitare donc ça m'a interpellé un
petit peu et puis jusqu'au jour il m'a
joué un morceau là j'ai fait ok d'accord
on commence il faut qu'on commence à
faire un truc à faire un truc ensemble
il y a eu un coup de foudre musical
finalement vos deux univers étaient déjà
à la base proche ou ça a été justement
cette espèce de petit coup de foudre
cette découverte qui a fait que
en fait ils sont ils sont pas forcément
aux antipodes nos deux univers mais ils
se rejoignent
bon c'est des prix de la tête
et
après on a choisi torrent pour le pour
le côté contrasté entre la force imagée
d'un torrent plutôt le côté rock et et
la côté le label le côté berceuse plus
doux parce que Greg en fait au départ
était plus dans le dans le métal voir
hard rock
le nom torrent dans le torrent et puis
moi c'était un peu plus parce que
j'écoute un peu plus calme donc côté le
Labaye pour la berceuse et finalement et
du coup le mélange c'est ce qui marche
bien je trouve donc aujourd'hui voilà on
peut dire que ce mélange fonctionne très
très bien donc vous produisez un sur
scène régulièrement quelle est vos
influences justement musicales à chacun
on va peut-être commencer par par vous
oui alors moi c'est plus tout ce qui est
musique anglo-saxonne américaine et puis
américain et comme et comme alors
Damien Laurens
you flagone là c'est plus américain
on a j'aime bien sigurros mais ça c'est
islandais et en fait c'est Agnès Obel
c'est beaucoup dans la dans la mélodie
et dans la voix c'est particulier c'est
plus dense oui je pourrais dire plus
dans la mélodie qui me qui me
et pour vous moi
je
dirais on a siguiros en commun en tout
cas avec Guy ça se tourne à quelques
trucs qu'on aime bien tous les deux
c'est vrai que c'est plus relativement
calme et posé moi un peu plus énervé
même si c'est un peu moins avec avant
malgré tout mais je sais pas ça va être
des groupes comme des Ocean par exemple
ou Alceste un groupe français et puis
des trucs un peu plus classique dans le
rock je sais pas du Nirvana du après il
y a tellement de choses que voilà ça
peut être assez variable dans tout ce
qui est rock rock métal quoi et des
trucs
indépendant et vous êtes alors
régulièrement sur sur scène dans les
Yvelines en 2021 à la batterie notamment
à Guyancourt mais aussi dans des bars et
restaurants du territoire en février par
exemple vous étiez au Copains d'abord à
Fontenay-le-Fleury l'essentiel pour vous
c'est justement de rencontrer le public
d'échanger avec eux de leur faire
découvrir votre musique en live
c'est
je dirais c'est un peu plus atypique
notre
façon de jouer donc moi je suis plutôt
content de voir c'est un peu différent
je pense que les gens pas l'habitude de
voir ça peut-être enfin en France en
tout cas
après
se laisser moi je sais pas après on a
peut-être pas la même vision des choses
à ce niveau là mais c'est d'abord jouer
notre musique en live en fait après avec
évidemment le but c'est que les gens
apprécient ce qu'on fait en tout cas
passe un bon moment quand il regarde
évidemment c'est je crois que c'est pas
pour tous les musiciens on les artistes
mais c'est voilà c'est sentir sentir la
vie de la vibration d'un allèle quoi
tout simplement avec son son qui
t'arrive
dans la gueule ou derrière quoi on met
la disto quand on a des des réserves
plane ou autre et après évidemment si
les gens apprécient bah c'est la
récompense quoi alors justement comment
est-ce que vous jouez votre musique vous
avez parlé de de reverbes typiquement
moi qui ne suis pas musicien je ne sais
pas spécialement ce que ce que ça fait
ce que ça peut produire ce que vous
pouvez vous nous expliquer justement
c'est un peu compliqué
résonances
puis nous c'est un peu plus particulier
parce qu'on
comme on a deux guitares acoustiques en
fait généralement on utilise plus ça sur
les guitares électriques mais nous on
aime bien avoir le son de la guitare
acoustique en même temps alors les
pédales ça fait
quelque chose de particulier un plus
entre les guitare électrique et la
guitare acoustique en fait
cette année j'avais si pédales sur mon
board vas-y achète-toi une
et puis j'en ai voilà j'en ai 12
maintenant
alors le 24 juin vous participez à la
fête de la musique à Rambouillet
organisé par l'usine à chapeau comment
cette collaboration pour la fête de la
musique a-t-elle été possible et ben on
a tout bêtement comme
n'importe quel groupe amateur je dirais
on a on a on a candidaté l'an dernier
pouvait jouer on a eu le grand plaisir
d'y jouer grâce à grâce à Lucie
et son gros boulot de programmation sur
la fête de la musique et on a passé un
super moment en plus on a rencontré on a
rencontré Yann était régisseur de la
scène sur laquelle on bossait on bossait
on a joué c'est super sympa et puis
et voilà
candidater parce qu'on a passé un super
moment quoi que c'est je pense c'est la
meilleure fête de la musique du coup
enfin c'est une vraie fête de la musique
et qu'est-ce que vous avez prévu
justement pour cette fête de la musique
est-ce que qu'est-ce qui attend
finalement les les personnes qui
viendront pour cette pour cet événement
Simone une question
on aura sûrement par rapport à l'an
dernier on aura sûrement trois nouveaux
morceaux a priori après on n'a pas
forcément prévu de se maquiller ou de se
déguiser ou voilà on restera nous-mêmes
c'est ça qu'on ça qui se passera et puis
voilà si on peut si on peut être encore
meilleur que l'an dernier bah tant mieux
quoi et alors pour se faire pour se
faire une idée on va écouter un extrait
d'un live que vous avez fait en 2022 et
on poursuit juste après
[Musique]
alors vous avez sorti deux musiques la
première s'appelle torrent et la
deuxième s'appelle mind roads j'espère
bien le bien le prononcer de quoi parle
ces chansons
en fait moi dans le j'ai pas vraiment je
cherche pas à voir passer un message ou
quelque chose c'est vraiment ce que je
veux c'est la mélodie c'est une émotion
parce que vraiment en recherche c'est
vraiment l'émotion et à travers la voix
et il y a pas vraiment de charge pas à
faire un message ou quelque chose si je
pouvais chanter un yaourt et rien de
dire que c'est absolument rien dire je
serais content en fait votre principal
objectif finalement c'est la mélodie
c'est l'atmosphère il cherche quelque
chose et qui capte et qui soit peut-être
différent mais et une couleur quelque
chose en fait si on devait essayer de
kiffer finalement sur scène et de faire
kiffer les personnes qui qui viennent
vous voir qui viennent vous écouter
puis de te faire de nous en fait déjà la
base on va dire enfin moi c'est comme ça
que je le vois c'est essayer d'être
content et c'est apporter une réaction
aussi on voit en face et c'est
oui c'est vraiment
ce que je recherche sur mon émotion max
en fait comme j'ai quand j'étais jeune
j'ai eu beaucoup de concerts et à chaque
fois je cherchais pas savoir les paroles
c'est vraiment la mélodie qui
m'intéresse et parfois il y a une
mélodie c'est pas ça vient comme ça
et si on est moi ça toute la nuit on se
dit
c'est ça qu'on a envie de
d'écouter revoir votre mélodie sera à
découvrir donc le 24 juin lors de la
fête de la musique à Rambouillet merci
beaucoup à tous les deux d'avoir répondu
à nos questions pardon peut suivre votre
actualité sur votre page Facebook ou sur
Instagram torrent le laby la
programmation pardon de la fête de la
musique de Rambouillet sera bientôt
accessible sur le site
usine à chapeau point FR et pour revoir
ou réécouter cette émission rendez-vous
sur notre site et notre application
radio sensation
[Musique]